welcome to the heavy spoilers show
i'm your host paul and this video we're
breaking down what the ending of black
summer season 2
and trails this series has got a lot
going on with it
and in this video we'll be recapping the
story talking about the final few scenes
and giving our review of the netflix
show if you don't want spoilers then
going past this part of the video
is a grave mistake and you'll just be
slowing us down
make sure you like the video if you're
not brain dead and of course don't
forget to subscribe for videos like this
each and every day
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into black summer
season 2.
now in case you need a recap of the
first season then for the first part of
the video we'll be picking your brains
by walking dead the journey that the
survivors went on
so it's really bad puns now i'll also be
going through the plot of season two
beat by beat
but if you just want to skip ahead to
the ending then time codes are below
now season one started after the
outbreak of a deadly virus
this turned everyone into undead flash
eating monsters
that would stop at nothing for some
finger food
through the eyes of rose and several
other survivors we saw the rise of the
zombies first
hand and we followed her as she
attempted to rescue her daughter anna
after fighting through thick and thin
rose and her group managed to make their
way to a stadium
that had been advertised as being a safe
haven initially it seemed like a dead
end
however her daughter and several other
survivors emerged
and we cut to black now black summer
season 2
should be called black winter as it's a
completely different landscape for the
most part
but it's just as tense and nail-biting
as the previous entry
whereas the prior season had people
simply battling against the undead
and the occasional school child season 2
is very much about the group going
against the elements
however it also throws in the element
that when the chips are down
humanity will very much turn on itself
in order to survive
humans are self-centered and selfish for
the most part and seeing how they will
happily step over one another
just to get five more minutes of life
makes for some incredible moments
nowhere is this exemplified more than in
the opening of the
show we join lance who you might
remember from last season
and within the first two minutes he's
killed by a couple named luke and sophie
so that they can take his car in the
first season he had an
entire episode where he was constantly
chased by one of the undead
it was sheer nightmare fuel and he
somewhat reverses this when he becomes a
zombie
as he chases luke until the character
crashes his car in the opening
getting rid of such a big main character
early on after all he was trying to do
was help people
is a brilliant way to start the season
and it lets us know instantly that
humanity will be the real threat here
this nail in the coffin is hammered home
when we cut to four months later
and see a sole survivor in the snow
being chased by a zombie
he makes it to a house and mercilessly
he and the walker are shot by a sniper
who we later learn is actually rose we
then see two men fighting in the snow
during the midst of an ambush and
whatever preconceptions you had it
becomes very clear
early on that this is going to be about
man versus man
versus dead man so bad now there's a
line in the show in which they say
nobody is good anymore and i think that
this perfectly sums up the whole season
most shows and movies have a macguffin
that the characters and villains want to
get a hold of
but black summer is very much based
around making it to a certain location
the first season was of course about
reaching the stadium and this one is
about making it to an airstrip
if we go in chronological order then we
pick up with rose
anna sun and spears out on the road
attempting to get there
however they're forced to make decisions
that split them up
but their paths do cross later on in the
series now son attempts to save spears
who rose was ready to leave behind
but in doing so she's captured by a
group led by a man named ray
rose and anna make it to a house in the
wilderness and here they're given
sanctuary by a group of survivors in
sight
however we know from the way that the
story is told that she and anna end up
being the only two survivors there
and they're willing to kill to keep a
hold of it the house is a great setting
and in the season it perfectly
demonstrates why rose goes from someone
who's willing to trust others
to someone who's ready to turn her guns
on them after one of the survivors heads
out to get medicine for his mother
he doesn't return and his brother sonny
starts to suspect those inside
are plotting against him he commits
murder which in turn births a zombie
and this forces rose to kill everyone
left in the house
the only survivor is a man named freddy
who is hiding up a tree after going out
to get wood
but such a grand location on the market
is quickly sought after
we see that rey has learned of the
airstrip too and he and his group decide
to storm the house
elsewhere on the road spears comes face
to face with a man named brathwaite
and we learn about his past spears's
life before season 1
was always ambiguous and all that we
knew about him was that he was a
criminal
however this is cleared up and we learn
that he's actually called james
james or rather little james used to
carry out hits for his brother
big james who i have no idea why they
were both called james if they're
brothers but
never mind anyway little james tried to
kill brathwaite when he was younger
but he of course survived unlike most of
the characters in the show though
brathwaite and james decide to let
bygones be bygones
and the pairport ways realizing that the
future is more important than the past
now unlike most of the characters in the
show because they choose to do this
rather than turning on each other the
pair survive their journey is laced with
lots of metaphors
and though might be reaching in the
wilderness they do see a black rider on
top of a white horse
which is thought to be the
personification of death when we look at
religion
we never learn the identity of this
rider and though this mysterious figure
stalks them throughout the landscape
they never end up dicing with death
brathwaite even refuses to shoot him
when he has a chance
and if our metaphor is correct then this
might be why he's spared
his journey ends with him and james
coming across the horse by a stream
and james almost of mice and men's him
but he lets him live
it's a really emotional scene that shows
the character arc james has gone on
and i really hope that next time we do
come across breath wait and the
perspectives are switched several times
as are the actions with rose receiving
sanctuary in the house before taking it
over herself
and denying it from others the show
jumps back and forth between the time
periods
showcasing the origins for certain
characters and the aftermath of their
actions
i very much felt that this had a last of
us part 2 vibe in that we had two clear
sides in the show
that we both saw things from the
perspective of though it would be easy
to say why one was good and the other
was the villain
both were clearly doing what they had to
survive making for a really
thought-provoking narrative that would
constantly have you switching sights
after losing the house rose and co head
out into the dead snow
with a man named boone he promises
there's a magical place where
on our way there yes with the food all
under one roof it's called elk valley
lodge now here
rose anna and boone find a great setup
and they decide to lay low there
james arrives on foot after hearing
about it from brathwaite
there's a very tense exchange but
ultimately both have come to accept what
they are
and who they've become even if they
don't like them james has realized that
he is in fact dying
and that he can either turn into a
zombie or end it before then
we learn that he's been attempting to
take his own life but he can't do it
unless he asks anna to kill him instead
anna shoots him
and these actions very much affect rose
as she realizes that she's hammered into
her daughter the idea that you should
leave people behind
if they slow you down james those slowly
dying
just wanted to lie low and live out his
final days at the lodge
he said the grass wasn't always greener
and that the air strip
might just be another dead end ana
clearly thought the opposite
and i think we can make the connection
that rose viewed her daughter as
following in her footsteps when it came
to just cutting off the dead weight
the season ends with all factions
converging on the airstrip and it makes
for one hell of a finale
a group of survivors led by a man named
leda are the first to arrive
and rey and cole follow shortly after
sun is with the ladder
whereas boone is with the former and
he's killed and allowed to turn so that
he can slow anyone else down who arrives
at the airstrip
rose and anna hide their guns and
surrender to rey and when the undead
arrive
they all hide in a hangout which turns
out to be a trap put in place by the
leader
rey is badly beaten up but before
anything else can happen
more zombies converge on the area the
plane comes into land
and using a flare gun that she nabbed
from a first aid kit
rose shoots some explosive barrels that
send both her and ray flying back
she's badly injured during this and
though anna ends up leaving her
in the end she refuses to board the
plane the words of james still clearly
ring in her head
and she doesn't leave her mother behind
rose's actions showed that she would
dump people at the first sign of trouble
but anna very much goes against this in
the end realizing that people are
stronger together
anna ends up finding her mother at
death's door potentially about to become
one of the undead
ray and anna have their guns pointed at
one another but they lower them
realizing that it's pointless the pair
both lay down to die
and their fates are both left as a
mystery now a big question that you
obviously have here
is whether rose is alive or dead and
there
are really two ways that you can take it
firstly rose closes her eyes as she
breathes heavily
but then they shoot open almost as if
she's defined
however anna looks at her before taking
her eyes to the road
almost to symbolize that she knows her
mother is a goner
and that she's gonna have to head out
into the world on her own
the fact that she doesn't go out to help
rose i think does showcase that she's
dead
and if we're being honest for how badly
beaten up she is
i can't see her surviving past this
point rose was very much about teaching
anna how
violence only leads to more violence and
that if humanity wants to survive
they have to work together the plane
very much represents this
and sun gets somewhat of a happy ending
for the meantime when we realize that
the pilot can speak korean
it's nice that she can find some
commonality with someone finally but
we still don't know where this is going
or why it made so many dangerous trips
in order to pick people up
i kind of get the feeling that something
far more sinister is going on
and james is warning that the grass
isn't always greener definitely rings in
my head during this
now we do know that this show is a
prequel to zed nation and though there
have been conflicting reports over
whether it ties in or not
every time i look into interviews about
the continuity they always make it clear
that things are connected now because of
this i actually think this plane might
tie in with the vaccine experimentations
that set up that show said nation took
place three years into the zombie
apocalypse
and we learned that several people were
unwillingly forced into taking part in a
vaccine test
in order to see if there was a cure for
the disease though it pains me to say it
i really think that this is where sun is
headed off to and it's the only reason i
can think why a plane would make
constant trips to pick people up
remember this show is very much about
how humanity will turn on one another to
get what they want
and keeping that aesthetic in mind it
just seems like the most likely thing
sorry guys now we also see in the finale
that a character named mance survives
i think that next time he and anna will
team up and head out together
they might even head back to the lodge
and it is possible that here they will
meet brathwaite
we still of course also have the radio
signal that they may start to
investigate
and the next destination that they head
to could be where the plane was going
however we do know from the refueling
comment that this is very far away
banana does have a car so they could
eventually reach it
though it would take a lot of time now
that's definitely where i can see the
season going
and as for my thoughts on the show again
i really really enjoyed it
i'm going to say outright yeah and sit
down for this i think this might be
my favorite zombie show and due to its
use of one
takes scenes non-chronological
storytelling and the plot reveals
it's a blast to get through last season
had its critics
but i absolutely loved it and season two
is no different
whereas season one was more about rose
fighting to get her daughter
this season is very much about keeping a
hold of her in a world that's slowly
becoming more and more dangerous
rose is a completely different character
to what she was in the first season
and she's ready to kill any person she
comes across
even if they think the wrong thought
bloody thought police
am i right now this makes her way more
complex and it's relentless watching
them going from tense situation to tense
situation
when discussing rhodes with screen rant
jaime king who plays her said that the
creative team
very much went in with the idea that
rose was dead
i don't mean literally so hold your
horses but this idea that rose was
completely dead as a person
king said she studied mothers who had
been through traumas involving their
children
and she used real-life instances of how
it changed them to shape her character
even decisions like cutting her hair so
that it was shorter than season 1
was done to show that the old rose was
gone in the first season
she was far more hopeful that society
could return to normal
however here this change is done because
short hair is practical
will cover her ears and keep them warm
and it can't be grabbed
because of this there's a real feeling
of authenticity here another main
complaint is there's not much character
development
due to them not really speaking to one
another i think through their actions
they show how they are
black summer was brilliant to me and if
you hated it guess what i don't care
i absolutely loved it it was a bit of a
difficult series to score
as it had some really high moments some
low ones but overall the good
far outweighs the bad black summer was a
blast
and it gets an 8.5 out of 10. now
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on the season
and the ending so make sure you comment
below and let me know as a thank you for
interacting with the video you'll be
entered into a prize draw on the 30th of
june
in which we're giving away three copies
of the mcu phase 3 box set
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the season the winners of
last month's competition are on screen
right now
so if that's you then message me on
twitter heavyspoilers if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out our breakdown of army of
the dead
which will be linked on screen right now
we've gone over all your unanswered
questions
and brought some clarity to it so
definitely give it a watch if that movie
left you confused
without the way thank you for sitting
through the video i've been poor
i'll see you next time take care peace